let's go to david from colorado david
you're on the air next
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
great i wanted to talk quickly about uh
democratic ideals uh given that so many
supreme court justices have been
appointed by
presidents that have not won the popular
vote correct do you support the
supreme court still as an institution do
you believe it has a rightful place in
our democracy i believe it has a
rightful place in our democracy but we
need to be confident in it and we did a
story on the wednesday show about how
confidence in the supreme court has
collapsed and it's even worse than
you're pointing out so david correctly
points out right now five of the nine
justices were chosen were nominated to
the court by presidents who lost the
popular vote so it was roberts and alito
by bush and then gorsuch uh coney
barrett and kavanaugh by trump that's
five of the nine justices were chosen by
presidents where more people voted for
their opponents but it's even worse than
that david in addition to that
one of them quite literally should have
been barack obama's selection gorsuch
should have actually been obama's
nomination of merrick garland mitch
mcconnell got in the way of that but
then it's even worse than that not to
really depress you today david but also
the completely anti-democratic senate
where wyoming gets two senators
and california gets two senators even
though california has 30 something
million people and wyoming has not even
a million people
they
are the ones who voted to confirm these
people so it's a completely
anti-democratic process and i understand
why there's very little confidence in
the court right now but
if we could make its makeup more
legitimate as an institution i do still
think that having a supreme court is an
important thing
right right and i'm totally with you in
terms of the anti-democratic uh
uh
institutions within our system between
the electoral college and senate i'm
actually from wyoming okay i've
why do you guys have two senators you
know
yeah no it's completely uh ridiculous in
my opinion but uh uh
do you have any specific reforms in mind
something that was talked about during
the 2020 campaign by pete butterjudge
was a
possible makeup in which maybe five
justices are appointed by the
conservative
nominee are rather conservative
presidential candidates half or five are
nominated by the liberal uh presidential
candidates and then the remaining five
are uh nominated by the ten
seated justices do you have anything
like that in mind or any other systems i
am open to a lot of reforms one idea
that is i think similar to what you're
suggesting but not exactly it is that
you always have a 5-4 court and it's
just whoever's in power in the white
house gets the five rather than the four
that's one idea that i've seen floated
term limits is another obviously i would
love it if the president's choosing the
justices
won the popular vote and we could
actually say they actually were
reflective of the will of the people but
that requires getting rid of the
electoral college the other aspect to
this is there can't be if you're
president it
i think we have to just set a line and
even if you have a week left and you
nominate someone i think that they need
to get a confirmation hearing i don't
think you can even there it shouldn't be
an option for mitch mcconnell and
republicans to do what they did
oh i totally agree um a final question
on ro uh do you think this could be a
straw that broke the camel's back in
terms of democrats winning back a super
majority and we've talked about that i i
don't know yet i i think that this will
probably inspire some turnout for
democrats in november but i don't know
about a super majority that seems like a
bit of a stretch
totally get that i think not losing
would be i think not losing by as much
would be like probably the best they can
do
yeah
we'll see what happens in november i
suppose
absolutely
david from colorado thank you so much
for the call
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend
when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video